I think they're different times for
different kinds of people and different
kinds of societies for most of us who
live in the developed world so you know
you're of the US Japan you know anywhere
that's that's a developed part of the
world we actually are faced primarily
with a problem of information overload
and the you know the role of an
encyclopedia in that is to basically
summarized things for us if I want to
learn about albanie I don't want to go
and read 500 web pages I just want a
quick summary information and that's so
that's very valuable it's a sort of a
starting point for people to get a basic
framework and then go out beyond that
but for many parts of the world when we
see you know the growth of Wikipedia in
languages like Canada which is one of
the languages of India in in those
languages frequently the problem is not
an overload of information it's an
actual shortage of information there's
very little material available to people
not so many books published not nearly
as many books translated into most
languages as we would like to see and so
the Wikipedia articles can then be you
know in many cases the the first real
cheap easy source of information that's
available at all and so that's that's
pretty important I think it's really
important to that all of our work is
freely licensed so people can copy it
modify it redistribute it commercially
or not commercially we're starting to
see projects where people are taking
Wikipedia content and putting it on to
two CDs for example or printing it in
book form and distribute it in places
where there's very poor internet access
and very you know low levels of literacy
and things like this that's really
really important and it's important that
people are able to do that without even
asking us they can just basically take
the content and redistribute it because
that's the license we put it out under
because I think that's going to have a
really big impact in law
well you know it comes out that it takes
a very small number of people
participating to generate quite a bit of
information we know from looking at some
of the very big languages of Wikipedia
some of the bigger European languages of
Wikipedia have a very small number of
speakers so something like Swedish
there's several million speakers of
Swedish but yet they have a huge
Wikipedia so and normally you'll see
participation by you know 50 100 200
people would be enough to generate quite
a bit of work over a period of years so
a lot of this is going to come
organically a lot of this is going to
come as we see increasing penetration of
the internet access and different parts
of the world right now by typical
estimates there's around 1 billion
people online and it's estimated that in
the next five to 10 years we're going to
see the next billion people come online
well those next billion people are not
going to come online from the US and
Europe and Japan because we're all
pretty much online already they're
coming from South America huge boom and
Internet in places like Brazil from
Africa maybe a little slower India China
so people are coming online in droves
from you know non-english non-western
countries and they're going to be
adopting Wikipedia and they're going to
be building their own language versions
of Wikipedia so in terms of you know how
do we get it get it going there I think
a lot of it is outreach promotion
letting people know that it exists and
that that that they have an opportunity
to share in their own language but it'll
come
it doesn't suck as much as it used to it
still sucks so um you know I think that
you know a lot of great stuff has
already come out on the internet but I
think we're still at the very beginnings
of some of the things so we have these
you know huge community projects to
build all kinds of different works in
text and then we're just at the very
beginning threshold of what's possible
with video online right now what we see
you know for example at YouTube is you
know individuals posting their own
videos they're doing a little bit of
this and that it reminds me very much of
the early days of text on the internet
when you had old like geocities homepage
providers and so people were throwing up
all kinds of random stuff some of it
really good some of it not so good but
not really the community process around
creating things so I think that's one of
the big areas of growth in the future is
that as we get more and more people who
have enough bandwidth to be able to do
video online and the tools begin to
mature so that people can you know remix
and and cut and build things I think
we're going to see things like you know
sort of mass collaborative projects to
build you know political documentaries
with bits of footage you know sort of
man on the street footage from all
around the world and things like that we
haven't seen a lot of that yet but it's
coming very quickly
too much you know I think that a lot of
people are beginning to realize that
there are sustainable business models
that can be built around freely licensed
content around user-generated content
that's placed under a Creative Commons
type of license for example and I think
that's that begins to help resolve some
of the classic issues that we've had you
know for a long time the whole copyright
debate was really bogged down in a very
polarized situation with you know some
you know very alarmist ideas that the
music industry is going to collapse
because everybody's stealing their
content online and or you know the the
content creators are going to take
control of the internet and people won't
be able to post whatever because of the
copyright issues but now we're starting
to see well actually there's a more
balanced approach the idea of saying
some rights reserved that people can
share things under various licenses
starting to see a lot more maturity
around those issues so I'm reasonably
optimistic that it's really not that big
of a problem I mean I just no idea is
just really huge and very popular and
very good and getting better all the
time you know I feel that you know
giving that to the world is well that's
great that's enough I still have lots of
great ideas and lots of things that I'm
working on but but to date that's the
that's the thing that I've accomplished
so far that I feel like you know when
people look back on the internet you
know 200 years from now and they look at
the early days of the internet which is
we're still very much in the early days
they're gonna look at wikipedia in there
they're gonna say you know that was that
was something that was good that was
something that people came together and
did something useful and oh that's
that's something I'm proud of
there are several different problems or
challenges I think you know one of the
concerns that I have is the the issue of
software patents is one that concerns me
a great deal most of the computer
industry will agree that software
patents are a bad idea that they don't
really work they don't foster innovation
actually hinder innovation and the way
patents work it's very different from
copyrights so with copyright you can
know whether or not you violated
someone's copyright as long as I didn't
look at your code and copy it I'm fine
but with a patent I may not even know
I'm violating your patent and these days
you know in the US patents are being
granted for the most trivial and idiotic
things and it's a real problem it's a
problem that is beginning to date in
danger and threaten innovation so far
anyway the European Union has rejected
the notion of software patents and
that's really important I think it's
something the US should reject as well
as soon as possible because it can
really instead of having this culture we
have right now where you have just
radical innovation month after month
year after year we know we could be in a
position where a handful of players
could gain an advantage in the market
that's more or less permanent I mean a
17-year patent is essentially an
infinite amount of time on the Internet
it's completely unreasonable so for me
that's that's one of the concerns I have
don't respond i'm not as pessimistic as
some people i mean sometimes when people
look at levels of broadband penetration
and things like that where we don't
necessarily rank in the very highest
rank i think that some of those
comparisons are a little bit invalid in
other words trying to figure out an
economical way to get broadband internet
access throughout the entire united
states which is quite a large place with
many many remote places where people
live it's very different from supplying
broadband internet access in South Korea
for example of our Finland these are
very small places by comparison very
concentrated populations I think that
the biggest advantage that the US has
with the Internet is something that we
should really be very careful about is
it's still the best jurisdiction you
know I in many ways for freedom of
speech and the First Amendment is of
enormous importance for the Internet
it's kind of an interesting thing
because in the past you know the First
Amendment rights for most ordinary
people had very little actual impact you
had a secondary impact in other words is
important to me in 1970 that the press
is free and that books can be published
because then I can consume all of those
things but as a person producing content
to share with others the First Amendment
had you know very little impact on my
day-to-day life nowadays it's it does
right we can all publish we can all
reach out you can all have a voice and
that ability is really you know it's
really important that we have freedom of
speech because that's what generates
this amazing bounty of great stuff so
today that's you know that's it's really
not a problem i mean the First Amendment
is constantly under assault from from
here and there in yon but for the most
part it holds up reasonably well
so one of the things that excites me
about the future possibilities of text
technology in the next few years is
something that I already spoke about
earlier which is the the next billion
people coming online I think that's a
really fascinating thing because I think
we're we're really at a threshold point
here right now the participation on the
Internet is basically people who we
already here from all the time anyway so
Europe Japan even China and so it's you
know that's an interesting cultural
dialogue that's going on every day in
millions of places all over the internet
but what's really coming next is you
know the next group of people coming on
from you know India and Africa places
that frankly the media gives us very
little information about unless there's
a train bombing or something and those
people will come online and basically
interact with us directly and we're
going to learn a lot about different
cultures in a way that we maybe haven't
before for me that's a really exciting
development you know the first time that
we'll see you know you know millions of
people online from Africa talking to
list so I think this could be passed
me